if you're worried about your hormones
you're going to want to watch this
[Music]
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's Kitchen in today's video we're
going to be talking about endocrine
disruptors in your diet and what you can
do to help reduce your risk a huge shout
out to my colleague Erin Davis for
assisting in today's research Aaron is a
fellow Rd and diabetes educator
practicing from a weight inclusive lens
so if you guys are struggling with your
blood sugars definitely reach out she's
amazing I'm going to be leaving links to
her contact below and don't forget to
hit up my description for my full
disclaimer plus links to my free
downloadable hunger crushing combo ebook
and my ltk page if you're wondering what
I'm wearing today so I just realized
that I read like a million research
papers and government documents saying
pfas in my head when the actual
pronunciation is pifas I know so
deceiving right anyways we're gonna
hilariously dub it over for the rest of
the video just for some Giggles so let's
set the record straight on endocrine
disruptors in our food The Good the Bad
and the Ugly endocrine disrupting
chemicals or edcs basically can change
the body's function by mimicking
blocking or interfering with the body's
natural hormones now this is not fake
news folks this is a legitimate threat
so we mostly take in edcs through what
we eat but we can also be exposed
through inhalation and through the skin
now unlike most environmental toxins
that we see a lot of Wellness
influencers harp about online edcs can
build up in our fat tissue so they end
up having a pretty long Half-Life in
other words they stick around and
accumulate over time
now we're exposed to hundreds of
different potential endocrine disruptors
every single day but some of the main
ones that we hear about in the media are
things like arsenic bisphenol a or BPA
pifas and faltates phallicates sulfates
you guys know what I'm talking about
someone with all the consonants all
smushed together that one so what's a
big concern with all these forever
chemicals leaching into our Foods well
research in this area is constantly
emerging but there is very likely enough
evidence to Warrant some concern and
mindfulness in some of the products that
we use or consume so let's very quickly
review some of the most concerning
evidence to date number one diabetes and
metabolic disease so research suggests
that exposure to the forever chemical
arsenic May impair glucose homeostasis
and is linked to an increased risk of
type 2 diabetes and in slim resistance
number two ADHD so lots of really
interesting emerging research when it
comes to the diet and ADHD
um I just shared a video about my own
diagnosis right here but some research
suggests that phthalate exposure in
adolescence may be associated with
neurodivergency conditions like ADHD and
then there's fertility so this is
another one that's interesting to me
because I am an IVF mom but the reason
suggests that exposure to phthalates has
been linked to decreased sperm counts
histological changes in testes impaired
ovarian function reduce fertility and
pregnancy complications like miscarriage
prolonged pregnancy and preterm labor
also we gotta talk about cancer always
there's lots of talk about cancer so
this is again related to the infertility
concerns but exposure to phthalates may
be associated with reproductive cancers
in women some research also suggests
that it may increase the onset and
development of prostate cancer and
breast cancer another one that I really
didn't know much about until I started
reading up on it is immunotoxicity in
infants as if new moms need an another
reason to be freaked out but there is
research to suggest that exposure to
pifas breast milk May reduce the
efficacy of some vaccines that are given
to babies and then of course we can't
talk about anything in the health world
without talking about obesity and this
would be a huge topic that would likely
require a dissertation to unpack and I'm
sure there's been many dissertations on
this I'm not going to do one myself but
a lot of edc's like BPA pcbs and
phthalates are considered to be
obesogens this review right here offers
a really great in-depth look at the
literature to date but as an example
this study found that high exposure to
bpas in childhood was directly
correlated with childhood obesity and
there are a lot of other studies with
similar findings and honestly the
research is fascinating for a science
geek like me but there's a lot of data
here lots of correlations with different
edcs so if you want to know more about
that specifically let me know in the
comments below so now want to talk about
some of the major sources of these edcs
in our diet and I first want to start
off by saying that I am in no way trying
to fear Monger I want you to know that
it is next to impossible to avoid all
edcs in life they're literally
everywhere so even if you were to never
touch a piece of plastic again boots are
washed in water that has some level of
contamination and we're exposed beyond
our diet and things like cleaning
products Fabrics Cosmetics nail polish
dental floss and a lot more so avoiding
edcs all together should not be the goal
this has got to be a risk benefit
analysis you know it's all about what
small changes can we make to our
lifestyle without making ourselves go
say so I hope this gives you a little
bit of insight into some of those small
manageable changes to help reduce
exposure for you and your family so
first let's talk about one of the most
ubiquitous sources of edcs water so tip
number one do not just stop drinking
water I just want to clear that up for
the extremists in the back because we
all know that someone's going to assume
that that's the solution bad idea but
anyways edc's can enter our water system
through a variety of sources so water
disinfection byproducts industry and
livestock contamination disposal site
and landfill leakage and therapeutic
drugs that can be released into the
sewage system and while we don't have
any really good Nationwide sampling
studies independent sources have
reported some pfas in most tested
samples of rain and tap water thankfully
the EPA recently updated their standards
in March 2023 to work alongside Biden in
his environmental justice plan to reduce
PFA levels in our water systems and
Canada is also working on our own water
Improvement strategy so how can you
limit your exposure while staying well
hydrated well first of all it's never a
bad idea to get your tap water tested
for contaminants if you're on a well
water system it's likely safer to be
using balls of water though bald water
is stored in plastic which we will
discuss also as a concern in a minute
but for most folks your best bet is just
to use like a high quality carbon filter
to filter your water at the tab and then
to store that water in a stainless steel
bottle not in more plastic also if you
are using plastic water bottles never
put them into the dishwasher to reuse
and always store them in a cold dark
place ideally in the fridge if they heat
up in your car
because I'll get rid of them this coffee
today is strong what the did I put
in here coffee time
next let's talk about a common food
source Seafood so fish and shellfish are
actually one of the major food sources
of pfas in our diet when the FDA tested
718 samples all of fresh and processed
foods 97 of them were pfas free but of
the samples that did test positive 14 of
them were seafood and then when they
specifically tested 81 samples of
seafood they found pfas in 74 of those
samples so no different than mercury in
fish we see the greatest levels of these
forever chemicals in filter feeders like
clams other mollusks like oysters and
also in larger fish who eat a lot of
smaller fish are friends because the
contaminants can more easily accumulate
so when it comes to fish specifically
some Studies have found higher levels in
farm cod fish others found higher levels
in wild caught fish and one study found
higher levels in wild or Farm just
depending on the fish so that piece can
be complicated it's not so easy just to
like go with one or the other and know
that's a better bet but the good news is
that with the exception of one canned
clam product that was tested from China
none of the other products were found to
be at levels likely to be at risk for
human health that said I understand the
desire to be prudent especially if you
are a heavy Seafood eater or if you're
serving fish to vulnerable populations
like kids or pregnant folks so my bottom
line when it comes to fish is not to
completely avoid it because we know that
having fish a few times a week is not
only safe but is hugely beneficial for
your health but to limit our exposure to
some of these contaminants number one
check out local advisories to determine
what fish in your area may be safer or
more at risk chew use fish more often
over things like mollusks or filter
feeders and go for smaller fish that are
naturally lower on the food chain like
light canned tuna trout salmon and cod
case in point I'm making a little salmon
snack for my lunch next let's talk about
canned foods so we know that a lot of
popular convenience foods are packaged
in different types of plastics and other
materials with varying concentrations of
edcs and for decades canned goods were
lined with an epoxy resin based on
bisphenol a and then we later found out
that those bpas could migrate into the
moist canned food bpas are no longer
even allowed in any kind of baby
products and according to Industry
analysis today about 90 to 95 percent of
food cans are made without BPA Linings
that said a lot of experts are now kind
of weary about products that are labeled
as BPA free because they may potentially
contain Alternatives including its
sister compound BPS which may carry
similar risks the research and analyzing
BPA Alternatives like BPS has suggested
that the swap really needs to be better
assessed due to concerns that they too
may affect the reproductive system my
take is I don't think we need to
completely eliminate all canned foods a
lot of canned foods are great
inexpensive source of nutrition and like
we said the vast majority nowadays are
BPA free but I would say when you have
the option choose a Jarred product or
frozen or dried foods over canned
whenever possible and if you are buying
canned again store them in a cold dark
place and check that the packaging is at
least BPA free now speaking of plastics
let's talk about storage containers
50s called
Anna wants its Tupperware party back but
the good news is that as of 2010 the
Tupperware brand and I would imagine
most of its competitors are now
completely BPA free that said as with
the bpas in cans most of these products
still contain other plastic compounds
like BPS which as we established may
still be concerned so the easiest
solution here is to switch mostly to
Glass storage containers I like that I
can just put this straight to the
microwave which is definitely not
advisable for anything that is plastic
they're also a lot more durable for
long-term use
[Music]
and if you do still want to use a
plastic Tupperware for storage just make
sure to check the bottom you can look
for the recycling code and you'll want
to avoid anything with a seven or three
this one says five so I personally will
just use the plastic for cold items like
washed berries and my little tip is to
line the plastic with some paper towel
to soak up the moisture but also to
create a little bit of an extra barrier
just to be extra prudent and safe moving
on let's talk fast food containers even
if your favorite restaurant is claiming
to use BPA free materials and packaging
research suggests that people who order
takeout food four to seven times weekly
may be ingesting between 12 and 203
pieces of microplastics through the
containers which increases the exposure
to edcs we also know that the grease
absorbing paper is found on a lot of
fast foods are known sources of P fuzz
so Consumer Reports actually tested 100
food wrappers at all these different
popular fast food restaurants and they
found significant amounts in the
packages from Arby's Burger King
Chick-fil-A McDonald's even sweet green
boo I love sweet green don't love the
price but I love the salad
so obviously the simplest solution here
is to try to limit fast food consumption
which will have a lot of benefits well
beyond limiting edcs and in my opinion
those benefits are much more important
than the edcs but if you are a frequent
Fast Food flyer I would suggest choosing
non-greasy items more often and consider
picking up and bringing your own glass
containers if they often serve their
meals in plastic which is going to be
way better for the environment as well
and if that's too extra for you to like
be that person just transfer your food
into glass or on a plate as soon as you
can and never reheat The Leftovers in
the original packaging now another food
packaging example that I don't hear
people talk about as much is my crave
popcorn so in like movie style bag of
popcorn the bag is meant to keep all
those buttery oils from soaking out and
like the grease repelling fast food
papers we talked about these are also
known sources of
and in this case not only is the popcorn
sitting in that packaging but then we're
heating it up in the microwave which can
further exacerbate the transfer of those
edcs so if you love popcorn as much as I
do like I'm
obsessed with popcorn I don't think you
guys understand
my love for popcorn
you can either try occasionally popping
it on the stove which is honestly so
much fun my kids and I do it all the
time for Giggles it is a great Pastime
great way to spend your Friday night let
me tell you or you can opt for like a
pre-popped bag low-fat popcorn and then
add your own butter when you're serving
finally let's talk non-stick cookware
we've been talking about the risk of
Teflon in non-stick cookware since the
early 2000s because Teflon is a known
source of pea fuzz and it's one that we
happen to heat up pretty hot on the
stove which makes it the perfect vessel
to transfer those forever chemicals into
our food so one type of PIFA in Teflon
called pfoa and I know this is getting
confusing as but pfoas were phased
out of non-stick cookware production
back in like 2002 but it's possible that
a lot of the non-stick cookware still
contains fifas that may be damaging to
our health especially when overheated
the good news is there are a lot of
cookware Alternatives so cast iron is
really your best bet it will last you a
lifetime but there's also a lot of
Cheaper options that are anodized or
ceramic coated or carbon steel or
stainless steel to help lower exposure
to those edcs and if you are using a
traditional non-stick just try to
replace it every few years and avoid
overheating it which can cause the pan
surface to flake and then transfer those
edcs into your food I get that this may
feel like a little bit of Doomsday and I
will admit that even I sometimes feel
anxious when I think about all these
potential sources of endocrine
disruptors especially because I have two
kids that I'm trying to take care of but
again I want you to remember that these
compounds are everywhere and the biggest
risk is from cumulative exposure over
time not that one greasy McDonald's meal
that you had last week also manipul in
your diet isn't the only way to reduce
your exposure stain resistant coatings
on carpets upholstery in other Fabrics
moisture repellent clothing personal
care hair products paints and cleaning
products are all other common sources so
my advice is to consider which of these
sources are easiest to reduce or phase
out without causing undue stress if you
need your microwave popcorn don't worry
about it like maybe replace your plastic
containers with glass if you rely on
canned beans as a convenient cheap
source of protein no problem just try to
stop reheating your leftovers in the
package that they came in try to make
the choices that feel easiest to you
because ultimately stress is not good
for our hormones either and on that note
I gotta get this bad boy into the oven
that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on what you're personally doing to
reduce your exposure to edc's check out
my free Hunger crushing combo ebook and
I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]